hello everybody I hope you are good
Bitcoin seems to be in a very important
Zone in the chart and is this previous
resistance that we were talking in
yesterday's video
um you can see that right now it's
testing it let's see if we can test the
support or if not we want to look at the
next song But first I want to go through
yesterday's New York session because we
gotta be disappointed it was quite
boring first we saw at the end of the
institutional drop we saw London holding
everything good and then we would expect
in New York to start covering this large
red candle but New York was pretty
boring and decided to rent in this area
the SMP pumped slightly I think it was
like a 0 to 70 percent
Bitcoin didn't follow which is fairly
strange and then
at this point we were thinking okay not
much is happening here let's forget
about this pattern because it only has
one hour left it's not going to happen
anymore so I got off the charts and I
was waiting to see what AC I was gonna
do
last night and start trading today so
what am I looking at today what the
first thing is that
New York didn't pump so Bitcoin went to
the next song which was the 28 600 area
Okay that was the previous resistance
for three weeks
that we had in during March
you can see here
and now what we would expect is we have
two scenarios again it we could test
this solar support successfully and we
could potentially see a bounce
or it's going to go to the next Zone and
what's the next Zone well if you notice
here
we have a range for
a couple of weeks I think there was 10
days yeah for 10 days that's quite a
long time for Bitcoin we're in this area
quite a long time okay
with this I mean that if Bitcoin breaks
below this area and fails to test the
sonar support we would expect Bitcoin to
do something like this okay
and test this well the bottom of the
range at the moment I'm not in any
position that's the first thing I want
you to know but this is not Financial
advice so do whatever you want but what
I'm looking at now is a breakfast of
this Zone then a bit of sideways and
then when it breaks that's when I'll be
opening a short position targeting the
bottom of the range you can see right
now if you go to the one hour time frame
the in this zone I'm not seeing anything
interesting dice telling me to open a
position okay you can see some weeks
here
to the downside which are quite
interesting but Bitcoin is still looking
pretty heavy so if you start seeing more
of this type of weeks okay in this Zone
weeks weeks weeks then yes we will
expect the bounce maybe to twenty nine
thousand four hundred which is this
previous song okay but for now is the is
it still looking pretty heavy so I'm not
interested at the moment let's go back
to the photo time frame okay so
basically
if it makes me load this Zone a bit of
sideways then fall to the bottom of the
range and then I will open in a position
a short position in this Zone
this would be my first Target but I will
have a second Target and it's this week
over here you can see this Candlestick
has a massive wig that was never
retraced so we would expect Bitcoin to
Target the
twenty seven thousand four hundred
eighty five Zone okay
that I would be or setup now let's go to
High block Capital let's go to the
locations chart and see what they are
telling us
if we go through the liquidation chart
we can see that they're getting a bit
messy because there has been a lot of
moves
and the charts are getting quite a
message so that is liquidity pretty much
everywhere in the seven days time frame
we can see quality liquidity at the 31
400 Sun that's exactly above the
previous High because there is always
liquidity above previous highs and Below
previous lows and then we have some
liquidity
at 27 400.
it matches with the week doesn't it so
that's why it's quite an interesting so
for me the ads Confluence if you go to
the one month time frame we can see it's
getting really heavy here quite messy we
can see liquidity everywhere pretty much
but again
things that I've noticed is quality
liquidity at 31 300 as a seven day stand
frame says at 27 400 that's around the
fifty percent of the week and below the
next zone is at the 25
500 700 600 and if you watch yesterday's
video that was our high time frame
potential support okay so if Bitcoin
starts to lose the 27 400 then it'll go
to the next Zone around 25 500.
in higher time frame it gets
even more messy you can see but it's so
a lot of liquid this is a 22 600 let's
say let's see if they update because in
theory these positions are long Tower
open for example saying this Zone
and they didn't take profit so I would
like to see if they if it gets updated
and that is starting to close positions
as we go down or if they are holding
them and see for example say if we are
at the 27 400 how this area is starting
to look it might change okay
we're back to the charts I'm here with
my friend the dollar index chart and you
can see how this W pattern might be in
play because it swept the lows and now
it's bouncing
remember the Bitcoin trades against the
dollar so as long as the dollar goes up
Bitcoin can't go up Bitcoin will
eventually go down so these are the two
songs that we have in our chart remember
I think that was Monday's video okay we
were explaining this potential mode for
the dollar Index and we could expect the
dollar to reach these zones maybe a
reaction here or the next Zone another
little retrace okay if you're in these
three traces we could see Bitcoin
bouncing but as long as the dollar
continues going up or marching on
Bitcoin will continue going down so keep
an eye in the dollar Index let's have a
quick look at the SMP chart we saw this
week over here so we would anticipate in
SMP to retrace and fill this week that's
what happened and now I think it's kind
of like in a sideways move let's go to
the four hour time frame
okay
right now it's a 4125 I think it's very
likely that it comes down all the way to
4100 which is around this one why
because if you go to the Daily time
frame well when I see a liquidity pool
over here
let me Mark it for you
this one okay so I think is heading
towards the Zone but I want you to pay
attention to this song Because if it
comes to the Zone I don't think he'll be
looking bearish let me show you why we
come
from a quite bullish
sorry a bullish move to the upside and
if it comes all the way here then I
think this will just be some sideways
look at this
okay it's sideways sideways from a
bullish move that's all it'll be Bo if
it breaks below this Zone then
it'll be a different story because it
will probably go all the way but a
little bit of sideways probably in the
zone and then go all the ways to the
four thousand Zone that it's a very
psychological Zone because it's a round
number I think that if the SMP goes all
the way to the 4000 then Bitcoin will
probably go to 25 500 which is a high
time frame previous resistance that
might get tested as support okay but
there is Journey for the SMP to go there
because first he has to come to the 4100
and let's see what it does there thank
you so much for watching guys I
appreciate it and I'll see you soon